[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel coge Marie
Vastel qu'on est heureux de réaccueillir
au panel bonsoir Marie et moi heureuse
de vous retrouver et les collègues
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé que ça a été
long de vous revoir alors bravo
évidemment que l'affaire elgawabi encore
monopolisé les chroniqueurs politiques
et les journalistes sur les collines
j'ai offert entendre monsieur Trudeau
c'est un peu plus long l'extrait parce
qu'il s'est longuement arrêté sur une
explication sociologique en disant que
les Québécois dans le fond était plus
libre que les Canadiens anglais on
voulait être libéré de toute religion se
méfiait de toute religion et donc notre
rapport à l'Islam et pouvait interprété
par d'autres comme de l'intolérance je
résume mais
on va écouter monsieur Trudeau réaction
les excuses de Madame el-ghaouabi
réactions excuses qu'on revient après
les Québécois sont parmi les plus
ardents défenseurs des droits et
libertés individuelles et ça vient d'une
place dans l'histoire récente ou avant
la Révolution tranquille le Québec a été
soumis à une religion qui
ne respectait pas ses droits et
libertins individuelles et donc les
Québécois ça fait d'une bonne place de
vouloir défendre l'égalité homme-femme
de défendre les droits des individus
défendre la communauté LGBTQ
cette défense des libertés des droits
amène une certaine distance ou même
méfiance de la religion et donc
ça c'était mêlé un petit peu avec cette
idée
d'intolérance envers les autres mais
c'est pas ça du tout
l'équipe
veulent juste que tout le monde soit
libéré et soit complètement libre
je l'ai dit que les gens Québécois ne
sont pas racistes ce n'était pas mon
intention et pour le blessures que j'ai
faisais avec mes mots je m'excuse
sincèrement et je comprends les effets
du mémo et je veux vous rencontrer je
veux entendre plus je veux bien
comprendre l'histoire québécois
je pense que ça démontre à quel point
c'est une personne sensible qui est
ouvert aux préoccupations des autres qui
veut justement bâtir des ponts dans un
dossier qui est difficile il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de travail à faire et
elle va aimer la bonne personne pour le
faire
c'était une bonne chose à faire mais je
ne pense pas que ça rétablit tout le
temps qu'elle a préalablement causée
donc c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]
je pense pas qu'elle a la légitimité la
crédibilité pour jouer le rôle qu'elle
doit jouer
avec vous donc le gouvernement le goût
ne change pas sa position elle doit
quitter vous avez entendu les excuses
les explications de Monsieur Trudeau
qu'en pensez-vous
la version longue vous explications de
ce Trudeau est ainsi difficile à
comprendre il y a des moments où là vous
avez pris le bon goût il est
relativement clair déjà
dans cette affaire-là il ne veut pas la
congé dire il sait que certaines de ces
déclarations étaient tout à fait
imbuvables au Québec mais en même temps
il dit il y a d'autres d'autres motifs
de l'autre côté à Québec on a été un peu
expéditif
la motion de l'Assemblée nationale
adoptée avant même qu'on entend la
personne parler moi j'ai un petit
malaise avec ça là alors
moi j'ai hâte de voir ce que Monsieur
Blanchet veut dire demain c'est lui qui
au moins il lui a parlé il verra on
verra ce qui ce qu'il pense de la
situation mais
du Québec dans un film en disant Audi a
le terrain par terre on peut faire ça
trop trop dans ce dans ce dossier au
Québec bon Marie est-ce que la nature
des excuses
aurait pu faire réfléchir même le
gouverneur du Québec et les autres
partis qu'il a dénoncé en disant bon ben
là à cette exclusion elle était
militante
tournons la page on est en avance où
ou non
compte tenu que le gouvernement du
Québec a été si expéditif dans sa
réaction comme le disait Michel C je
suis pas certaine que les excuses
allaient changer quelque chose parce
qu'on n'a pas attendu de voir s'il y en
aurait avant de s'indigner donc je suis
pas tellement étonné de leur position
je suis pas certaine que les excuses de
Madame changent beaucoup les opinions ça
permet peut-être à des libéraux fédéraux
québécois où on sent vraiment un malaise
là au sein du caucus par rapport à ce
qui a été dit dans le passé et
possiblement par rapport à aux propos de
Monsieur Trudeau au départ qu'il a
défendait tout azimut peut-être que ces
excuses vont permettre aux élus
québécois fédéraux de de pouvoir
continuer d'être à l'aise qu'elle reste
en poste parce que certains ont critiqué
ces propos passés mais personne n'a
demandé quel kit bon ça leur permet
peut-être de garder cette position là
mais ce que je trouvais intéressant dans
ce que Monsieur Trudeau a dit
aujourd'hui c'est que cette longue leçon
d'histoire comme vous dites on avait
peut-être un peu l'impression qu'elle
s'adressait aussi à Madame pour calmer
le ton de son côté à elle aussi parce
que quand on lui a demandé au Premier
ministre si elle comprenait cette
perspective là qui est celle du Québec
il a pas répondu il a dit qu'il était
content qu'elle s'apprête à rencontrer
le chef du Bloc québécois Québec
solidaire dans les prochains jours
monsieur Trudeau a aussi dit là comme
vous le disiez que ça c'était quand elle
était militante c'est une chose
maintenant ce sera différent parce
qu'elle est représentante du
gouvernement pas certaines que Madame el
ghaouabi pense la même chose parce que
quand on lui a demandé si elle se
sentait la bonne personne justement pour
ce rôle le contenu de toute la polémique
elle a présenté son rôle comme étant
celui d'exprimer les peines des
minorités religieuses donc on a
l'impression qu'elle appelle au dialogue
que dans sa tête son rôle c'est de
partager un côté de ce dialogue le
lancement et Véronique je vais vous
faire entendre avant de donner la parole
Véronique monsieur Legault c'était avant
les excuses ce matin mais comme le Parti
libéral du Québec vient de dire là je
viens de voir un tweet du chef en disant
nous on peut trop tard aussi donc on se
range comme du côté du gouverneur du
Québec mais monsieur Lego justement
avait ça en tête ce matin on écoute
le Parti libéral du Québec dit aux
parties libérale du Canada qui devrait
changer sa décision qui devrait congé
dire la dame là je pense que ce truc
Trudeau un vrai problème
bon Véronique monsieur Legault là
pas piéger les libéraux mais les
libéraux ne se sentent pas la force
d'aller contre cet ordre là quoi non
puis en fait ce matin c'était profil bas
quand même du côté du gouvernement parce
qu'ils avaient l'impression qu'hier ça
avait été une bonne journée le Parti
libéral Québec solidaire c'était empêché
aujourd'hui c'était à eux d'essayer de
pas s'enferger davantage mais évidemment
que les excuses de Madame elgahouab pris
nos tournures à la journée parce qu'on
s'attendait pas à ça nécessairement
Jean-François Robert j'ai été assez
clair c'est à dire qu'elle a perdu la
légitimité la crédibilité aux yeux du
gouvernement mais ce qu'il ne dit pas
publiquement et que plusieurs dans son
gouvernement pensent c'est qui certains
doutent un peu de sa sincérité c'est à
dire qu'en fin de semaine elle tentait
de se justifier encore plus ils disent
ben c'est après cinq jours finalement
qu'elle s'excuse après que Justin
Trudeau l'enseignant nous a fait une
longue explication de en réalité pour
montrer qu'il est connecté quand même
encore au Québec donc eux avaient
l'impression qu'il y avait quelque part
un exercice de relation publique et
qu'elle est finalement sortie quand elle
a vu l'ampleur au Québec la motion et
tout ça pour en quelque part conserver
son poste donc eux trouvent qu'elle veut
remettre la pâte à main dans le tube
puis confond elle disait clairement ça
pensait
à quel moment on peut dire à quelqu'un
on vous étiez militant vous avez exagéré
comme à peu près tous les militants de
toutes les causes sur la planète peuvent
exagérer c'est ça le militantisme c'est
un peu religieux par définition donc
vous avez exagéré mais là vous avez un
nouveau poste on verra qu'est-ce que
vous ferez tant on sera jamais d'accord
avec vous mais on verra on n'aurait pas
pu je suis naïf on n'aurait pas pu
répondre ça Michel
il y a plein de
politiciens à l'Assemblée nationale
comme la femme des communes qui disent
pas la même chose qui ont dit il y a 10
ans sur un sujet ou sur un autre je me
souviens que Monsieur Legros avait déjà
dit que le Canada
les gens ont le droit de changer et
c'est pas juste la fonction il faut que
ça soit autre chose que juste dire ah
maintenant j'ai une nouvelle job donc je
dis pas la même chose que ce que je
pensais avant ça c'est une autre affaire
mais il faut quand même donner un espace
aux gens pour évoluer puis changer un
peu là la condamnation était rapide sans
appel terminé merci bonsoir
au moins comme je disais tout à l'heure
au moins on aurait dû l'écouter et je
pense que
au cours des des dernières heures on a
vu ses excuses on a vu que elle ne
pensait pas nécessairement tout de mal
qu'on pensait qu'à penser
Marie est-ce que rapidement là-dessus
pour conclure est-ce que le chef du Bloc
québécois est une formalité demain on ne
s'attend pas est-ce qu'ils disent
d'accord j'accepte les excuses je
considère qu'elle peut rester en poste
ce serait surprenant ça serait
surprenant c'est ce que j'allais dire on
verra demain lui lui a parlé en privé ou
avec peu d'adjoints et un député lui en
sait peut-être plus sur l'évolution de
sa pensée justement que nous tous qui
lui avons pas parlé faut dire aussi que
Pablo Rodriguez va lui parler demain
jeudi le lieutenant québécois de
Monsieur Trudeau on verra si du côté du
caucus du Québec de Monsieur Rodriguez
la pensée évolue mais effectivement je
soupçonne que demain monsieur Blanchet
il a dit lui-même ne deviendra pas son
premier fan il pourrait peut-être à son
tour demander la démission de madame
agawabi
très bien mécanisme c'est le monsieur
barretier de l'ancien grand patron
témoigne
au moment où on se parle actuellement il
dit je prends un ami de Monsieur Trudeau
les contrats c'est pas moi etc or le NPD
pose une bonne question à Michel C
pourquoi on examine pas les gros
immenses qu'on trouve aussi que l'on
donne à deloyd à eux seniorgne enfin
toutes ces grosses films qui font encore
plus d'argent par cette habitude que la
haute fonction publique ou les ministres
ont fait de donner au privé des gros
contrats
c'était la pointe de l'iceberg c'est ce
qu'on voit quand on est dehors mais les
autres les kpmj qui se montrent
pas mal plus que ce qu'on voit alors
un moment donné c'est l'espèce de de non
confiante qui vient de la part du
gouvernement envers ses propres employés
qui est un problème il y a une fonction
publique et dès qu'il y a un problème
soit de de con ou qui exigent une
consultation extérieure soit un problème
un peu compliqué en informatique
ça marche mieux au privé il faudrait
redonner une chance à la fonction
publique c'est pas toujours la faute des
fonctionnaires c'est quelque chose
marche pas
la crise des passeports est une bonne
exemple ça pourrait fonctionner qui ont
fermé bureau de passeport pendant
pandémie qui sont allés travailler sa PC
ou sur d'autres affaires ces
gouvernements qui a dit que le faire ça
alors un un moment donné si on faisait
plus confiance à la fonction publique et
je ne doute pas qu'à ta voix est aussi
compétente qu'à Québec et oui bien
développeurs fonctionnaires aussi là ça
c'est vrai mais on aurait peut-être
besoin de moins de Mackenzie puis moins
de PNG dans la vie marie ou s'en va
cette commission parlementaire est-ce
que comment vous voyez les la suite là
je pense que Monsieur Burton s'en est
assez bien tiré aujourd'hui pardon et
fait peut-être en sorte qu'il va falloir
effectivement élargir l'enquête le NPD a
raison c'est sûr que c'est une bonne
poignée monsieur Barton ancien
ambassadeur qui a participé un groupe de
conseils du gouvernement c'est une bonne
poignée pour l'opposition de dire à
voilà le gouvernement
récompense ses alliés tout ça est cousu
de fil blanc mais de un monsieur Barton
un peu d'effet cette impression là en
disant qu'il a rencontré Monsieur
Trudeau une douzaine de fois jamais
seule qui l'a pas son numéro de
téléphone là c'est pas son ami et de
deux c'est un peu facile je pense qu'on
se trompe de cible comme je disais
Michel C si vraiment
mais qui reçoit bien moins de contrats
bien moins de millions de dollars par
année que d'autres films comme Deloitte
KPMG alors regardons l'ampleur du
problème et combien d'argent ne dépenser
là-dessus et pour quelle raison
je pense d'après moi l'enquête va aller
dans cette direction là parce que la
poignée commence à s'essouffler un petit
peu et de ce côté-là il y a énormément
de potentiels pour les semaines à venir
le pour l'opposition et à Québec on
prend des notes Véronique très
certainement ici étant donné que la
claque est majoritaire ça arrivera pas
là qu'on va entendre Mackenzie en
commission par le repère comme ça ou des
intervenants du genre mais par contre
effectivement les bouts qu'on a vu
jusqu'à maintenant de cette commission
on voit que Dominique Barton est
vraiment très préparée là il est en
train d'essayer de défaire le mythe
comme quoi la prise de décision est
sous-traitée par des films comme
mécanisé en disant par exemple à
l'immigration oui peut-être que vous
avez entendu que ces Mackenzie qui avait
aidé fixer les cibles mais à l'intérieur
on était tellement divisés en avait la
moitié qui voulait augmenter le nombre
d'immigrants l'autre moitié qui voulait
pas puis en fait on savait tellement pas
quoi faire qu'on a fait tiens au
gouvernement prenez votre décision c'est
un peu ce qu'il a expliqué donc il est
en train d'essayer de prendre cette
distance là du gouvernement pour montrer
que c'est pas vrai qu'une proximité
à suivre mais c'est devenu évidemment
c'est devenu parce qu'il y a eu des
enquêtes en France ici il y a des cas où
des questions se posent en effet mais
elle se pose aussi pour d'autres films
en deux mots c'est ce qu'on disait
Michel on peut pas juste regarder
mécaniser le reste ça va tout tout va
bien
pas très démocratique comme c'est bon
très bien bon ben Marie encore une fois
re-bienvenue à se Pennel a très bientôt
Michel à très bientôt véronique est très
bientôt bonne soirée au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI